in Georgia the church is calling on God
to protect the people from the virus
priests sprinkled salvation to mingle
with the snow and rain in tably seas
sameba cathedral hundreds of liters of
water were blessed for the purpose the
church continues to welcome
congregations its priests believe in the
healing power of prayer we see how hard
the situation is in our country the
whole world and how the virus is
spreading that's why the church has
decided to pray have identified fewer
than 40 cases of covered 19 with the
Prime Minister on Tuesday warned it's
now spreading among the general
population we are moving from the stage
of stopping the epidemic to containing
its spread this transition is very
important and we need to be ready first
and foremost of the health care system
Georgia has been preparing schools and
universities closed two weeks ago its
borders are shut and public transport is
about to be limited Orthodox priests
have refused to alter their rituals
their presence remains a comfort to many
for a deeply religious society at this
deep time of anxiety this is the
georgian orthodox church his way of
providing some spiritual support and
guidance at these difficult times robin
Forestier walker al jazeera tbilisi